pascale rickets has invented a game
called three rolls to ten you roll a
fair six-sided die three times if the
sum of the rolls is 10 or greater you
win if it is less than ten you lose what
is the probability of winning three
rolls to ten so there are several ways
that you can approach this the way we're
going to tackle it in this video is
we're going to try to come up with an
experimental probability we're going to
do many experiments trying to win three
rolls to ten and figure out the
proportion that we actually win and the
more experiments we try the better the
more likely that we're going to get a
good approximation of the actual
probability so let's do that and to help
us I'm going to have a computer generate
a string of random digits from 0 to 9
and the way that we're going to use this
is remember we're rolling a fair
six-sided die so the outcome could be 1
2 3 4 5 or 6 for each roll in this
random number list that the computer has
generated I do get digits from 1 to 6
but I also get the digits 7 8 9 and 0
and so what I'm going to do for each
experiment I'm going to start at the top
left and I'm going to consider each
digit a roll if it gives me an invalid
result for a six-sided die so if it's a
0 + 8 a 7 or 9 I will just ignore that I
will just say well that wasn't a valid
roll it's like you roll the die and it
fell off the table or something like
that so let's do that let's do multiple
experiments of taking three rolls sum
them up and we'll see how many we can do
to figure out an experimental
probability of winning
Pascal's game so let me set up a little
table here so I want space to show the
sum so this is going to be the
experiment experiment so let me write
the sum and over here we're going to say
did we win
all right so let's start with experiment
one so our first roll we got a one our
second roll we got a 5 we're doing quite
well and then our third roll
we got a six did we win
well one plus five plus six is 12 yes we
won let's do another experiment this is
going to be experiment two we can just
keep going here these are random digits
so we have a six in our first roll we
got a two in our second roll
we got a four in our third roll did we
win yes once again this sums up to
twelve so we won all right let's do
another experiment so experiment number
three so this first thing is invalid so
this is our first roll we got a six and
then this is invalid our second roll we
get a three
this is invalid that is invalid that is
invalid and then in our third roll we
got a two so we squeaked by this adds up
to eleven yes that looks like a win all
right let's do our fourth experiment
here so our first roll we got a 1 this
is invalid second roll we got a 2 this
is invalid third roll we get a 5 did we
win
one plus two plus five is eight no we
did not win so that's our first non win
so let's keep going this is interesting
all right
this is invalid so we're going to have
so this is trial 5 we are going to have
4 plus 3 plus 1 4 plus 3 plus 1 adds up
to 8 did we win no let's just keep going
here so I'm going to keep going with my
table where I have experiment I'll do 5
more trials X bar
and some and do we win let me make the
table this is just a continuation of the
table we had before I don't want to go
below the page because I want to be able
to look at our random numbers here so we
are on to experiment six experiment six
we are getting a three in the first roll
a three in the second roll this isn't
looking good and then a two in our third
roll did we win no this is less than 10
now we go to experiment seven experiment
seven we get a two in our first roll
this is invalid we get a three in our
second roll plus 3 and we get a 1 in our
third roll so plus one once again we did
not win now we go to experiment we will
go to experiment 8 we get a 1 in our
first roll we get a 3 in our second roll
this is invalid the die fell off the
table we can think of it that way and
then in our third roll we get a 5 plus 5
did we win
no this adds up to 9 so we had a string
of wins to begin with but now we're
getting a string of non wins all right
now let's go to experiment 9 so we get a
6 in our first roll we get a 4 in our
second roll and then these are all
invalid and then we get a 5 in our third
roll did we win here yes we won over
here this is definitely going to be
greater than 10 this is 15 here
alright last experiment or at least for
this video last experiment you could
keep going in fact I encourage you to
after this to see if you can get a more
accurate a better approximation of the
theoretical probability of winning by
doing more experiments to calculate an
experimental probability so here your
experiment 10 first roll we get a 5
second roll we get a 2 this is invalid
invalid
invalid then we get a 6 here we
definitely won so with 10 trials based
on 10 trials or 10 experiments what is
our experimental probability of winning
this game well out of the 10 experiments
how many did we win it looks like we won
1 2 3 4 5 so based on just these 10
experiments we've got a pretty clean 50%
so do you think the theoretical
probability is actually 50% maybe you'd
want to continue running these
experiments over and over maybe we'd
want to do a computer program that could
run this experiment set of 10 times
maybe 10,000 times to see if we can get
closer to the true theoretical
probability